[Music]
hey everyone welcome to harry potter
theory what you're about to watch is the
much anticipated gameplay footage from
the upcoming harry potter game hogwarts
legacy avalanche software and warner
bros games have been teasing the game
for quite some time so it's nice to
finally have some footage for the much
anticipated game i'm also going to be
answering some frequently asked
questions about the game but i'll save
that for after the footage as i'm sure
you're dying to get in please enjoy
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
i don't know about you guys but that
looks even better than i expected anyway
as so much time has passed i'm sure a
lot of you have many questions so let's
dive into some faq first big question
when will hogwarts legacy be released
well as it turns out despite rumors that
the game could get pushed back to 2023
this footage confirms that the game will
be released holiday 2022
the next question is what platforms will
hogwarts legacy be on according to the
official website for the game it will be
available on lots of different platforms
including playstation 5 playstation 4
playstation 4 pro the xbox one family
devices including xbox series x and xbox
one x and of course pc
the next question is how does hogwarts
legacy fit into the harry potter
wizarding world the game creators had
this to say while port key games are not
direct adaptations of the books and
films the games are firmly rooted in the
harry potter universe while remaining
true to jk rowling's original work port
key game developers chart new territory
by creating fresh ways for fans to
immerse themselves in the wizarding
world essentially what that means is
this
they're using rowling's framework and
will be staying true to the wizarding
world that we know but we'll also be
introducing some new concepts
the official website also mentioned the
following
while hogwarts legacy is not a direct
adaptation of the books and films the
games are anchored in wizarding world
lore avalanche is creating a unique
gaming experience that is inspired by jk
rowling's wizarding world in which
players will find new and unexpected
locations characters and story elements
a good follow-up question to that one is
is hogwarts legacy an original story the
story of the game has players
experiencing life as a student at
hogwarts school of witchcraft and
wizardry like never before as i live the
unwritten and embark on a dangerous
journey to uncover a hidden truth of the
wizarding world will we see ron hermione
and harry in the game unfortunately the
answer to this is no as hogwarts legacy
is set in the 1800s before the trio were
born
however i am certainly curious to see
how many easter eggs they fit into the
game so i'm sure fans would love that
is hogwarts legacy multiplayer hogwarts
legacy is not a multiplayer game but it
seems as though an mmo is on the cards
what kind of game is hogwarts legacy
what's the story hogwarts legacy is an
immersive open-world action role-playing
game set in the 1800s which puts players
at the center of their own adventure
players will experience life as a
student at hogwarts school of witchcraft
and wizardry as they embark on a
dangerous journey they will grow their
magical abilities by mastering spells
brewing potions and taming fantastic
beasts how do you play hogwarts legacy
hogwarts legacy is filled with immersive
magic putting players at the center of
their adventure to become the witch or
wizard they choose to be they will grow
their characters abilities as they
master powerful spells hone combat
skills and select companions to help
them face off against deadly enemies
players will also encounter missions and
scenarios that will pose difficult
choices and determine what they stand
for
can players choose and switch their
hogwarts house in hogwarts legacy
yes players will be able to choose their
hogwarts house at the start of hogwarts
legacy where does the game take place at
this time we know that the game will
take place in the hogwarts castle
forbidden forest and hogsmeade village
what is jk rowling's involvement with
the game is this a news story from jk
rowling jk rowling is not directly
involved in the creation of the game but
her body of writing is being used as the
foundation for the game the game will
not influence existing harry potter
canon at all who is developing the game
port key games from warner bros games is
the games label dedicated to creating
new wizarding world mobile and video
game experiences that place the player
the center of their own adventure
inspired by jk rowling's original
stories portkey games offers players the
opportunity to make their own narrative
choices and engage with the wizarding
world setting to discover new and unique
experiences
the label was created to bring gamers
and fans new gaming experiences that
allowed them to delve into the wizarding
world in immersive ways where they can
create their own magical stories
will dumbledore be in hogwarts legacy
the game takes place in the late 1800s
which technically means that since we're
going to be attending hogwarts we should
see some familiar faces there's also one
man in particular that i'm hoping to see
that was quite important in the harry
potter franchise
albus dumbledore ever heard of him
dumbledore was born in the year 1881 and
he started attending hogwarts in the
year 1892
provided that the game takes place in
the late 1800s i'm going to assume this
will also cover the 1880s and 1890s
which means that yes there's a chance
we'll see young dumbledore
who will be the bad guy in hogwarts
legacy
well if the footage is anything to go by
then we know that our hero will likely
be facing off against a goblin rebellion
led by goblin by the name of ran rock
ran rock and the goblins seem like
they'll be the main adversaries but
apparently we'll also be fighting off
against various dark creatures as well
as dark witches and wizards
and that's it for this video are you
guys excited for this game i know i am
comment down below if you'll be playing
also feel free to ask any questions i
perhaps didn't cover and i'll try my
best to answer until next time you're a
wizard dowry
[Music]